how you doing brian
hey
hey six nicotine patches in the [ __ ]
urinal
they don't clean it out well you can't
you can't just dump them you can't just
dump them in i'm here every day so i
believe this and i really want to say
this six is too much that's over like
days dude i'm here i don't think so i
think i promise that's for the days they
don't clean it up you don't put six i
just got into it with the landlord here
because chin there's no way a cleaning
crew comes every day there's no way i
leave [ __ ] out on purpose to see if they
come and they don't come so you don't
put six at the same time right he's got
them all right here
huh he's got them all right there's some
there it's a residue everywhere yeah is
there someone yourself you always have
nicotine in your always when you sleep
i sleep with nicotine
do you really no oh i was like but when
do you stop doing it uh when i get home
yeah
sometimes yeah when i get home yeah
nothing to me is better than a diet dr
pepper and some nicotine at night really
oh when i'm watching my shows uh-huh
snackies yeah snackies my drinks you'd
say at the end of the day
it's addictive no doubt you have you
have a problem you have you have an
addiction no i could stop if i wanted i
don't know you have an addictive
personality oh yeah you could stop and
then you get a little chubby for the
first time yeah but i think if i go cold
turkey you might get all chubby you
might just start shoving us around yeah
just the white tea today huh yeah yeah i
think hey i'm in a white tea we got this
i think at least has oh you brought you
got the bruce lee pants up oh always
naturally i just today i went i'm going
simple mm-hmm yeah
that's every day for you though yeah
yeah yeah you're never like oh today
it's all today's going to be
like met gala well in my car i do have a
a button down
but you know for me if it does feel
weird it's like a long sleeve bundle
easy to wear i i bought a
you'll like this
i had some money throw it at me i i had
fifteen hundred dollars in cash cash
yeah cash is always fun i was in vegas
and something about vegas and i uh i
don't gamble but i am walking by john
varvatos
yeah and i spot and i walk into i like
their shoes i like the other stuff
and they look like howard stern when you
wear it but whatever they had a wax
a linen shirt that was waxed it was a
waxed linen shirt like a jacket it looks
really good on the model it looks good
right it actually looks good on me
here's the problem we'll see here's the
problem
what color is it black yeah
the problem is
i might be a tad too old yeah yeah
wearing a squash roll waxed yeah sure
yeah unless you're ozzy osbourne it's
tough to pull off no dave grill shops
there
yeah dave is a huge rock star
but they're like the same age yep i get
it i get it but this girl is a rock star
chappelle when he touches the stage
thank you no he isn't wrong
man he keeps us on our side yeah yeah it
is tough to wear that stuff the problem
is i gotta get a convertible yellow
corvette you're wearing john varvatos
well so i'm i'm yeah some young chicks
in the shotgun i'm wearing that i got a
pair of designer jeans on and i had my
golden goose and i just looked great and
jed york who is the owner of the 49ers
looked at me and said now are you 25 or
and i was like
that's a billionaire yeah and i was like
he's right it's too hard of a flex for
you yeah it's just not your and also i
think if your hair was better you could
pull it off i'm not even being [ __ ] i
agree yeah i like that you try though i
like that you give things he does not
though he does
just that
little here's the other problem it's a
weird thing what i i have when i have
zippers and buttons and i have and i
can't move i feel restricted and it
seems like work to wear
it's just a lot it's a lot you like
comfort any guy watch have you ever seen
me wear a watch no because it's
it's too heavy
and you're kind of dividing you're like
the media yeah you like that media i
like
that's the video and we make all of our
attention not the truth yep blocked
do you know what uh finally hit and is
out of no and nothing makes me happier
when i go to watch a show and then
netflix's like oh just released the love
on the spectrum
season two
with autism yeah i didn't see the first
one you didn't see the first season no
um
you know what i don't watch those shows
i would already i just i just oh i they
should call that show
longing for something you'll never have
that's that's oh wow that is am i wrong
would you watch everybody
you're way off yeah i'm glad i'm old
you'll watch love violin though yeah you
watch f-boy island you want yeah you're
weird at fifty seven years old you're
watching you love island
my girl made me watch it yeah watching
and i just happened to have been walking
by love on the spectrum will make you
appreciate those kids who are on the
spectrum because they're special they're
special in like sub world like
it's definitely on a spectrum like some
are dude some like me and my girl
there's one this redhead kid and he
looks so sweet and so nice and he's like
27 and they all want to find love so bad
like they want to find a connection
because they're lonely and that's like
what they're focused on they say it's
like their life's journey to find love
yeah and like so the one redhead who's
new this season his is so bad like he's
27
and he sleeps in like you know like uh
like hot wheels sheets and he's like
really into cars and he's like he's just
he's got a child like yeah like in like
his demeanor is like very like yeah i
was telling my girl i'm like looks like
tiger like he's in the cars just the way
he talks it's like asking me tough but
so he's on over here and then there's
one girl on there who they show i was
telling my girl i'm like this [ __ ] is
faking it man to get on the show oh [ __ ]
and i was like i think she's faking it
man because she was completely normal
really but then when she went on the
date you see it and like oh [ __ ]
just like if there was like loud noises
it was all she could focus on she had a
panic attack and then certain things
like
if she gets like hooked on something
she's obsessed with it and just like but
so hers isn't like that bad but then
not on my girl i'm like you know like
that that redhead who's 27 who's like
and he's kind of like a kid i'm like
dude can they live on their own and then
when they set they sum up on blind dates
so though like there's one guy in there
he's like the main star i forget his
name but he was like on a speed dating
thing and he he doesn't want an uh uh a
girl on the spectrum he wants like a
regular girl so they pair him up with
regular girls and you can tell they're
you know they're being nice but yeah so
they don't at the end of the date they
check boxes who they match with and you
only get the number if you match with
people so they set them up with like
five regular people and you can tell
those girls you know they're they're
being nice
come on but it's not gonna go and it's
not gonna happen yeah but then there's a
girl on the spectrum the last one and
i'm like oh this is it man and he but he
he checked her but he wanted the other
two regular girls so that night they
call it he's the thing i love about the
show is they're so innocent but they're
very
direct yes they're very direct there's
no [ __ ] what they wanted
so when they call when they when the
lady calls to tell him who we match with
she's like oh you had one match and he's
like looking at his mom he's like yeah
he's like it's go time and he's like
okay and she's like oh it was whatever
heather the girl on the spectrum he's
like
[ __ ] you can tell he's like damn
he's like rachel didn't check the box
and she's like no he's like okay hangs
up the phone he's like well and mom's
like at least you have a match man his
mom's awesome because you have a match
something to look forward to the next
day he's like you know the more i think
about it although i didn't really like
her at first and the mom's like you
can't say that she's going to see this
but they have no filter he said you're
going to have no filter zero filter yeah
he's like i didn't like crap first but i
find myself thinking about it i really
like the other girl better than mom's
like she's to see all this dude quit
saying all this stuff but he just they
just let it out
i have a friend yeah you know and he has
a son who has who is essentially
spectrum
and what's interesting about him is he
doesn't have irony he doesn't have um
he's very direct so he'll be like you're
pretty you know or and it was so funny
because he's now he's at an age where
he's very smart very smart and wonderful
but he he he doesn't have
the ability to necessarily
uh
i guess maybe
see irony or humor like he's just
directly right and i said to him i go it
was such a great conversation i was
laughing so hard i said what's your
favorite animal and he goes
he goes an ant hitter
and i went
why and he said because they're majestic
but he's dead that was it yeah
why are they majestic he goes because
they can kind of run pretty fast and
they can climb yeah yeah you know and
you'd be able to saw it in your house so
why would you want that it was because
if it was in your house you'd be like oh
my god i can't believe that thing can
run that fast it doesn't seem like it
was yeah and that's and that's it and
the other experience i had with autism
was my friend's child
uh my ex amanda is really good with
children and she's she she's really
interested in child psychology and stuff
i'm not i just see a cute kid so my
friend has a kid the kid was probably
two i don't know
and um
and i'm we're playing i'm there and i'm
talking to her i'm doing this thing we
get in the car and my my
my ex is quiet
and i said something like kid's so cute
she goes yeah
i said what she goes
i'm afraid that child is autistic
and i went
you don't know that no he's not you
could you can tell when you're
if you're around kids all the time yeah
and she said she said that he never
looks at you yep they don't make god
yeah
yeah this one girl goes on a date on
there with this guy and she's so full of
energy and she's like loud she's never
been on a date and she's so loud and she
likes men or uh women like she you know
she but she's never been on a date and
she's she's a lot like oh this girl's
gonna make a tough sell and then they uh
pick
partner up with this dude and literally
so if the camera's her he's this way the
entire thing like he's just staring out
that way and he's like is it weird when
he keeps going like this he's like is it
weird don't you find it weird and he's
like acknowledged it he was like don't
you find it weird when people stare at
you in the eye
and she's like and but she was so cool
she's like oh i don't mind it yeah it's
kind of cool you don't look me in the
eye you know like she was cool about it
how about they want me
so bad man it's nuts but if you look
here's my question if you look if that's
a spectrum right
all of us have mental
acuities and tendencies
that we are probably born with right
like to an extent to an extent you're
born with uh like less fragile a mind
less fearful they find that with a lot
of kids right so some kids are just
naturally cautious some kids have
natural anxiety it is what it is and
they are starting to realize that that
is that is a hormonal genetic thing
inherited sometimes whatever it is then
there are people that literally
in the most extreme circumstances their
heartbeat doesn't raise those are
daredevils race car drivers and
bank robbers and [ __ ] like that yeah
they always say if a race car driver
isn't isn't
directed towards something productive
they become a [ __ ] bank robber you
know it's the i've never done that
before they gotta find something
psychologically you've never heard that
before but psychologists tell you that
when they were so that guy makes sense
remember that tag remember
no it's what it's done you don't become
a professional race car driver which is
impossible to do you're gonna rob banks
no um ice man the ice man so this guy
was the guy was looking at the ice man
and he was explaining he was he said he
said
you
they did this whole profile
psychological profile on and he said you
are the kind of guy
who doesn't get nervous about
extreme extremes he's like a snake
nothing bothers him you'll cut you he's
talking about cutting somebody up and
it's just started to smell so he had to
spray the room with drew caroner and
he's eating pizza at the same time oh
yeah
the guy said to him he goes you um
your personality type is found in people
that take great risks
you know these parkour crazy dudes yeah
[ __ ] uh race car drivers
he has something he has to beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of you his dad beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
his brother went away for murder and was
for life
and he went away and they don't talk to
each other in jail
so so but he said you got so destroyed
that that anger or that thing you just
got you found you found the place to
take these real chances
and it was really interesting it was a
really interesting breakdown yeah
oh yeah oh yeah yeah question for you
watching this show because i feel like
if i watched it i'd just be emotional
the whole time does it hit you mm-hmm
that way like like where you like kind
of like get teary-eyed not a match like
[ __ ] because you want them yeah yeah
yeah that's why i said long enough
because yeah i ever get that's why no
they they find it someone gets married
on there like they in the trailer i
guess someone gets married on there and
then and then one guy is like someone
what the one guy on there he was on the
first season like he's a tough sell dude
he's a lot he's when i say he's balls
deep in dinosaurs he's like 37 he loves
dinosaurs so when he goes on these dates
like a bird a fly band like you see that
bird and then for an hour he talks
he can go he goes and he tells a girl he
is i'm fluent in dinosaur and he just
knows his dinosaur that's [ __ ] he's
37 and he has like dinosaur toys yeah
yeah
the poor parents man i mean i'm sure
like you know they're all they're
obviously great people but it's just you
know it's tough man i'm just watching
stevie over there petting his dog that
that dog butters butters is that the
name dog it's a it's a blonde wiener dog
they went to you
stevie looks like a special forces guy
with a very
very uh delicate little doggy on his
he's tired
you look a little bit evil when you're
petting it that way
yeah you look like a bad guy
yeah yeah that has a cat usually you
just [ __ ] is a bad guy inspector
gadget
i like those sweatpants i'm not gonna
lie i'm a sweatpants guy
super comfortable you're looking thick
too stevie's a full-time uh dad now of a
dog yeah that's his life his life kong
was the dog cat
domesticated stevie you regular you
wrangled that wild horse in yeah
and eat the same thing day in and day
out yams it's a prison life chicken
breast
and it's it's beautiful to watch
so he wouldn't eat his original treats
they were like
meat things and then they had another
one that was chicken and sweet potatoes
mix
they're on the same diet
same day yes a dog's in me it's bound to
happen are you are you eating his food
cat are you on the stevie train uh not
really every now and then i try but i
fall off i can't eat the same thing day
in and day out
i can't do this i can't do it the boiled
eggs and the sweet potatoes can't do it
it's amazing the avocado the rice cakes
we'd be able to be on the road and the
first thing you do is you'd have a
couple cookie sheets full of sliced yams
yup delicious
chicken breast it was all there
every three nights he does that that's
impressive the best grilled cheese i
ever had was from stevie arizona yeah
arizona baby so i don't know what kind
what was that bread
ah what was that
it was that good bread
ezekiel
was it ezekiel famous
it was some bread that was [ __ ] fired
but yeah he lets me eat grilled cheese
once a year oh really yeah yeah damn
[Laughter]
no glute
[Laughter]
did your sister eat like you do cat no
my sister eats
the worst sister i've never seen a human
eat worse than herself oh wow is that
right nobody eats worse somebody she's
like fast food all the time
then make like
another like so make like a yogurt
parfait and then rummage through the
cupboards to see if there are any snacks
left over she's like you're great we'll
go yeah yeah she's like a gram like an
hour and a half straight she'll just be
in the kitchen she's by herself i love
her more no she's not heavy you've never
seen a cat's sister
yeah she's young though yeah so at third
if 30 she's still doing that that's
that's what stevie tells her all the
time like every day
no [ __ ] no yeah at 30 she enjoyed a sumo
wrestler
yeah
it's funny because stevie used to kind
of lie about it
it's funny because stevie used to be
kind of polite about he would say like
little snarky comments every now and
then like oh you're eating again huh and
just the other day he got so comfortable
with her that he looked her straight in
the eyes as she was like eating a
cheeseburger
he said you're gonna have diabetes
you're going to be fat at 30. yeah
she's pretty sure that tattoos
is 23
24.
look at that
yeah
are those only two tats she has uh yes
the leg and then the uh
she's a bonafide
you guys look a lot alike but i don't
want to get caught off
she's a very good looking woman yeah in
and out should sponsor
yeah
yeah she's very pretty
yeah i was like why would she get
sponsored by internet because she loves
it
in and out's great burgers overrated us
[Music]
shake shack is better shake shack is way
better yep
i don't like
it's christian's birthday was it oh yeah
yeah yeah
yeah you have the same birthday as liam
gallagher from
oasis how old are you christian i'm 23.
you're [ __ ] young man yes sir 23. did
you do anything for your birthday johnny
said he was gonna take you to vegas uh
yeah we might go this weekend on their
because we're usually me and my brothers
have this tradition where whoever's
birthday it is the other two take them
out and pay for the dinner but standard
yeah so instead of that this weekend
we're going to probably go to like we're
either going to go to vegas
uh
forks washington or like utah and let go
of uh ride atvs or uh dirt bikes and the
dunes and stuff oh [ __ ] nothing's
planned not yet we're still trying to
figure it out it's wednesday
yeah we're that's the best type of plans
of last-minute plans kind of vegas you
know as the ufc this bride
yeah we were thinking about that but i
don't want to go to vegas because
my brother and my roommate don't drink
or party
so
we're going to go there just like johnny
doesn't drink no he doesn't drink smoke
do anything oh wow yeah so
it'd be weird to just go wash these
fighters
on air yeah that's great
i just wanted a piece
oh boy
oh no
but eating on here gets to me yeah no
but it's triggering for me i've been
doing this for nine years
no not in
eating on air really triggers me i want
to beat you up right now
that's how bad it triggers me yeah
because as a viewer i'm right now i'm
like [ __ ] this show yep
yeah you know what yeah you
you stopped doing nicotine for a couple
minutes no i know a good podcast
yeah it's just you know and you know
what you're going like this dude you're
going like this another thing you're
doing this yeah you're starting to
flutter
yep arts racing christian you ate it
before the birthday boy that's what else
triggers me yeah yep it's his [ __ ] i
don't know you had birthday etiquette
you [ __ ]
it's his birthday
and you ate his cupcake hey hey mr
overreaction what's going on christian
would you like to come you ain't no
cupcakes before christian did you want
one yeah yeah give him one your head's
all naughty and you're getting it
it's his birthday
i don't give a [ __ ] about birthdays
don't put your birthday etiquette on me
god and you ate before christian
the cupcakes should have been near
christian yeah they really should have
should have been on our table yeah you
put them on my table well cat did
yeah and
you're a bit of a weirdo no i just like
to be polite man
oh my god and you're 54 and you don't
care about birthdays but he's 23. that's
a big deal give a [ __ ] it's twenty-two
birthday etiquette and about the fact
that i ate a cupcake and you're like and
before him
just saying and he's like this
damn and i wanted to get i wanted to get
one of cupcake before brian takes one
christian
would you how do you yeah how do you
feel let's ask him how he feels i don't
think he can chris yeah i don't really
care he didn't we did a show yesterday
he didn't even tell anybody it was his
birthday i had to find out from cats
good though you know what when you don't
even know about your birthday it's 20 30
too yeah like i'm not gonna be like hey
guys it's my birthday
say happy birthday look if you guys know
but yes what's going on man nothing you
know
i just feel weird like being like oh
yeah nothing's my birthday i i just feel
weird about that
yeah it is you're not a big birthday guy
ah it's just like it's just whatever day
like what you did you celebrated 21
pretty good right yeah i went i was back
in rhode island for that and i got [ __ ]
faced did your other brother drink uh my
oldest brother yeah yeah he drinks a lot
when he was he drinking when he raided
the capitol or no october that's over
that's right that's over it makes sense
in my acting class
that i was in for way too long there was
a young
a guy turned 32
in our class and it was his birthday and
he got up he interrupted the class of i
don't know 80 people
he got up and he just started going um
it's my [ __ ] birthday
and i'm just feeling
not working i still haven't done a thing
as an actor mental breakdown and i just
every time i see the [ __ ] clock he
had a breakdown in front of everybody
and the teacher goes keep going instead
of saying hi excuse me just let him go
well and he's like this and finally
what saved him was he's like i mean
every [ __ ] minute that goes by and
i'm still not successful the phone
doesn't ring i've been doing everything
[ __ ] right and this guy was brad pitt
screaming right no i'll tell you the
story and then he goes like this and
then after he's he's screaming for about
10 minutes we're all just listening and
he goes like this he goes
like 10 minutes ago i'm still not a star
you [ __ ] knew it and
everybody kind of cheered for him
and and he got this the teacher was like
that's the kind of attitude you want to
take that right yeah
then he joined scientology
and then did it work out did they get
them rolled up oh i never like this
guy's tom cruise i never
saw him well maybe he got balls deep in
scientology whatever he did it didn't
work out from an acting point of view
they they host like acting classes right
scientologist
one of the greatest things about being
in an acting school and i stuck around
for five years you know longer than
maybe was necessary not cheap either no
rogan used to always rogan used to
torture me mercilessly about the fact
that i spent
eight hours a week in acting class
torture but he had to do acting class
right yeah but he when he first got him
he was only doing stand-up and he was
like and then he [ __ ] yeah but
then he was on news radio right yeah but
we got an uncomfortable like shouting
matches in restaurants over it right him
making footy for being yeah back in the
day we got in these crazy arguments but
um
but what was interesting is that there
would be people in that class that would
be there for 10 [ __ ] years now
and it just didn't work out and it's
like
yeah but they would and i know that's
what that's the game the breakdown sweet
one dude got up and handed out pamphlets
that he made saying i am an artist love
it and he was establishing that because
this is my i'm making my mark yeah and
it was see back then it was all this
uh affirmative thinking you know that
positive thinking yeah will it it will
be no it doesn't work it doesn't work
that way and i i i i i told you like a
tony robbins talk yes and sometimes we
had anthony hopkins come in and talk to
us and it was like people were like oh
my god and somebody goes like this they
go uh
because you know an acting class man you
you have to prepare yeah you also have
to do research on the character there's
anthony hopkins comes in the equivalent
of the beatles a bunch of actors and
this is right this is in the what 90
this is probably 99 yeah
and he comes in and he goes uh somebody
goes how much research do you do on uh
your characters and hopkins because i
don't do anything
just shut all that [ __ ] down and i just
work on it it's called talent it was
like like brian when those when those
actors would come in they wouldn't give
people the speech like the football
coach gave
your team like where's like okay how
many do you think you're going to make
it to the [ __ ] no they're not those
actors aren't there today no
they're not going to do that you know
what neil simon said there wouldn't be a
business if every if big actors came in
to shut everybody down
because the chance of making it's like
you know you got a you had a hope neil
simon said the best thing neil simon is
was the great american playwright and he
probably had more of his plays turned
into movies than anybody in the history
yeah and you wouldn't know him now but
neil simon was the biggest he'd be the
equivalent of quentin tarantino or
something today you know but even bigger
and uh and he had a
40-year career 40-year career he wrote
the odd couple wrote i mean oh yeah i
mean forget it and um
and he said uh they said is there
anything you can tell the class and he
said uh yeah i mean i i if you what do
you what do you want to know and they
said success and he goes success he goes
yeah he goes well i'll just say that i
am the little man
i feel like a little man he was a little
man he goes who climbs to the top of the
stairs and i go to this little tower and
every day i write i spent eight hours
writing in front of my like it's so
lonely i'm just there writing and almost
always i fail almost always i fail one
in twenty one and twenty yeah and he
goes and that's success i never forgot i
was like well that's a legend saying
that yeah it's a legend he goes and he
said and then i talked to a producer and
i said i've written a bunch of scripts
but they're not good and he goes hey
brian i work with academy award-winning
writers every single one of them has
literally a trunk this big of scripts
they've written of scripts that were
total disasters
one
yeah that's why it's so hard to make it
though yeah everything that's right
especially everything yeah in everything
this is the weird because there are a
thousand other people you've taken
acting classes right you've been in them
yeah
i like it really yeah i actually do like
it it's pretty fun oh it's good you can
learn technique there's i don't think
i'm not saying acting doesn't require a
lot of techniques it's helped me see
those guys sure great acting carol
street they studied for years oh yeah
i'm not saying there isn't formal
training yeah sure it's just that
it's just the people that hang around
too long but it's also you gotta
remember too it's a business so the
teacher like you hey some are special
1299 a month you know well i saw a
different oh i had a woman come in i
swear to god i can't
she came in in new york city when i was
at the
neighborhood playhouse and she there was
like a special seminar we all went in
there and she was the one who was gonna
tell us she was the in the business she
was like uh producer slash cash director
or something and she had done a lot of
stuff and we're all these young waiting
to hear about this and you know what she
said i never [ __ ] forgot this did i
ever say this she said if you're a
beautiful woman sleep sleep your way to
the top use any angle you can get oh wow
and she goes and i know and she gave us
examples
if i told you the number of women that
made it because they knew how to sleep
with people strategically we were all
everybody was like did she get cancelled
or what no this was in 1990 this is
1991.
she was just telling the truth about how
hollywood worked we were all like holy
what do you do if you're a dude you
never forgot that yeah well yeah what do
you do if you do
no i mean no i'm not saying that a lot
of people really are good and they make
it but i'm just saying there was all
that it was whatever angle she was
saying whatever angle whatever it takes
use it that's what she was saying brian
your acting coach was jeff
jeffrey tambour who was damn boy yeah
yeah
solace who was i mean taught
everybody you can imagine every famous
actor in the world you had to get into
the club it was like a special [ __ ]
you had a basically audition for the
class invited into like a saturday class
and how long did you do it yeah
he ten over ten years yeah holy [ __ ]
thirteen years yeah
that's amazing and i mean i worked at it
i worked at it
but it worked i mean you had your own
sitcom on abc and you know
it worked [ __ ] work and you're able
to put that out there on the stage like
that's why i enjoyed acting classes
because
the uh transitions
no i haven't done it for
i wanted to be able to back in the day i
wanted to be able to
be across from anyone
no matter who it was and hold my own
yeah and i worked at that i think i
could do that no never i would never be
intimidated ever about acting with you
you know if you put in the work yeah
they're so long nothing would you ever
take them i've taken them are you taking
them oh you have oh she's a very good
actor yeah yeah like he has good because
we did firing kid 3d that's right the
best thing about you is that you you
it's very hard to do too i just said
don't do any acting nothing just go and
you did a really good job so that's
really hard to do some people can you
can have a whole career that way
you you could if you would if you had
been if the right people had seen you
you're the kind of guy that's very very
coachable yeah and so i i think that
with the right i could direct you yeah
for sure i definitely direct you into
looking really good in anything but like
a guy
like should he would like
what like you guys i don't know like
you know where you guys are at now like
if you still wanted to do acting
training would it just be better to well
he did do a class or like a one-on-one
season he he did this scene in fighter
and kid 3d where he had to play an actor
who had worked so hard at the role and
then he realizes that he's just being
used yeah as a guy who gets shot yeah
it was but the way he did it like
with mitch
was so good
and i remember watching it and it was as
good because you were so humiliated and
embarrassed
and in the scene it was so good because
you were
you were putting your [ __ ] back on and
answering questions and embarrassed and
mitch was great remember it was the
greatest it was so good it was so [ __ ]
up and you worked with some monsters
monsters remember those guys oh yeah
those dudes that you would recognize as
character actors yeah yeah and brennan
kept laughing at this one dude because
their face they can just do those subtle
things yes where you're just like you
believe them
like like when michael richards from
seinfeld i did a scene with him one time
yeah and we were just reading it and he
was he was pretending to eat cake
and i was like no wonder this
[ __ ] like eating cake and
kirstie alley was eating cake they were
like this guy and he was like well don't
really know i'm no i'm
i'm not telling you that and you're like
this dude's really eating
and he was doing he was taking he was
breaking off pieces
and it's like this weird talent but it
just hits oh yeah you know or
try playing drunk try playing really
drunk and angry or really drunk and
happy yeah try it tough
if i mean where you really believe the
person is my acting teacher one time in
school just started to pretend he was
drunk and and fell off his chair and we
were all i was like oh what the [ __ ]
how was he this good uh-huh how was he
this good you know so you would go to
acting at what was it like one o'clock
like that was those were the days right
so those were the days theater school
now remember this for two years in new
york city that would be all day all day
speech
dance singing
scenes dance i was there from 8 a.m
until 5 00 p.m you understand you go
home and you got to come up with like
another thing for the next day yeah it
was a formal training school for two
years you have to be invited back new
york second year and all that [ __ ]
yeah yeah neighborhood playhouse
um then when i came to la
i got mad tv then i get another show oz
and i realized and i got a pilot and i
realized i don't really know how to act
i still haven't still didn't yeah i had
i just was new
new to the game so i get into this
neighborhood the beverly hills playhouse
which you know all these big actors yeah
and that's where you i would show up at
7 00
p.m and you'd be in class until 12
a.m a lot of times and you'd do that at
least twice a week and then please if
you weren't doing that you were getting
ready to prepare scenes
then when you got invited into the
saturday class now when you looked in
the audience it was nothing but working
actors some very famous actors so now
would you audition then too or no no you
would do a scene now you put up a scene
in front of a bunch of
oscar and emmy award-winning actors you
know you you want to look good you want
to be and then they're like big time
writers and big show runners and you're
like i got to do really well here so
you'd be on such a weird world oh it's
such a weird word like i was watching
the emmys and you know when they get on
there and they're like you know this is
lifelong work and you embody the
characters like shut up
watch this it's like do you pretend to
be another person a teacher didn't like
that
but that's dope teacher is it
yeah no we do we give him too much
credit man teacher did this you're
sitting down and he goes like this he
goes he's
he's writing something now and he goes
um
what were you doing near the trash can
and i go when he goes you know when
what were you doing over there i don't
have time so you gotta you know and i go
i was dancing and he goes yeah
everybody he goes yeah not good
not
good
like all right and then he goes
have you ever has ever occurred to you
to look at the person
and act with the person you know there
was somebody did you know there was
somebody else on stage with you or did
you just want to do a show for us so
embarrassing how they humble you
humble you
the worst
the worst but
have you done any acting [ __ ]
well just with the thing that you did
remember what was it for your special
when you dress up as a girl you're
holding my hand yeah that's right that
and also i yeah you're you're my date
yeah yeah and voice acting i did a bunch
of voice acting oh that's right yeah
right oh no you're saying for rango sang
and also did voiceover stuff
for or for rango
first animated film that wanted the
academy award oh there was like a lizard
yeah yeah gekko or something yeah
country western gecko yeah or chameleon
i don't know yeah he's a lizard man but
you're into acting though he's doing it
now i just got into it yeah yeah acting
class that's what i thought uh not
classes yet because like they just
started opening all of them were over
zoomed so i didn't want to do that
that'd be awesome but um my friend who's
uh like a respect like he's been around
for a while like he's been in a bunch of
stuff he'll come over
and we'll like print out see uh sides
like he used to teach at james franco's
school so he'll he'll come over he's not
there anymore i know he doesn't teach
her anymore yeah the school's not yeah
you that's why yeah
don't go there yeah
no it's been on zoom but don't go to
school because not there anymore you
know well yeah yeah but uh he's been
coming and teaching me a little bit but
he'll come over and help me like do self
tapes and everything chris look at me
right now and i want you to really feel
this oh god oh so
the line is
he's
live brian
piece of [ __ ] the line is it's your
birthday the line is
i missed you dad
say that with a lot of feeling start
crying you say action
action
hold on dude
you can't laugh at the action you have
to be right
you're not helping you got to be serious
not good i haven't learned anything you
gotta give a direction you can't just
say not good it wasn't bad buddy can you
be a little embarrassed by it when you
say it
be a little embarrassed
well
you got this
wait champion
can
your lessons from james franco's
side piece or whatever [ __ ] it was right
action
yeah i said try it again and without
laughing action
i miss you dad
not bad
okay when you're playing embarrassed
just do always do it to something like
to that wax candle just be doing this
going i missed you then you know just
kind of
fidget or something yeah that's what
that's a good way to play it hide it
hide it all right take calend's uh take
my on his workshop i would love to i'll
help you with any audition you ever want
i appreciate that i promise i cannot you
can go on auditions and shake christian
i actually uh so i didn't even plan on
getting into the entertainment industry
a talent manager reached out to me from
tiktok and signed me and started uh
submitting me first off i actually read
for the movie that eric griffin just did
in new york
clearly i didn't get it but um if you
read for something
bring it here
all right yeah definitely don't just go
in there like that everybody does that
and it's a big mistake that's a good
idea i definitely know definitely little
details like that stuff you know yeah i
would this is wasted do you ever see
that uh that director or he's a casting
agent and it's over zoom and he didn't
know he was on mute and the kid's doing
it and he's like god's piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] place
is bigger than that the kid goes sir uh
i know my place piece of [ __ ] and he
goes oh my god i am so sorry nope it's
fine i know it sucks i'll just let me do
the audition i know my place sucks
yeah i [ __ ]
some casting directors would be eating
they just you'd have producers and they
just didn't eat [ __ ] yeah yeah
i mean they sit through so [ __ ] mini
but still yeah it's like [ __ ] you
don't do that some actors some actors
will [ __ ] call you out on it they'll
just do some crazy call out the castle
jimmy had to play a guy who's just
waiting hey better hey better no better
no better no matter come on you gotta
know about it
he's just he's he goes there eating in
there oh yeah and he's good okay
don't do it i just hear him going hey
better nobody know about it nobody
because he's yelling at the imaginary
battle who hit the
pitcher or
the batter who hit a foul ball and hit
somebody in the stands
jimmy was in uh wonder woman too oh yeah
yeah he's the one i was supposed to be
in that scene he's opening scene i know
i was supposed to be in that scene but i
was doing i was doing a movie or
shooting something
yeah bigger than wonder woman too
i uh
yes
okay what was it called
bigger than wonder woman
like i'm gonna go over here and do this
instead of
the biggest movie of the year i was
doing i had a gig yeah
yeah and and i and i i i will admit that
it was i i was called last minute and it
made me all mad
i was like i'm not oh it's an ego thing
yeah i was like no i'm not doing it yep
smart oh you're gonna win dude you win
man you win i'm gonna take my ball and
go over here not being wonder woman two
and then patty jenkins goes
cool yeah we're gonna stay no i i
genuinely couldn't make it i genuinely
couldn't get out of the commitment i was
doing i can't remember what it was but
it was a genuine there was a genuine
remember what this movie was it was
impossible for me to make it i remember
but
um but it was nice of her and you never
know what's going to happen by the way
it was pretty cool with today's low
interest rates it's a great time to
refinance your student loans earnest
offers low rate student loan refinancing
and you can check out your rate risk
free in just two minutes you hear that
butters get rid of student loans buddy
with earnest you get flexible payments
and he can pick your loan term he's
looking nice and off my hands by
refinancing you can reduce the loan term
save money or combine multiple loans
into one simple monthly payment you have
questions you can even talk to real
human at earnest for help all right
isn't it time you stop feeling
overwhelmed by student debt earnest is
offering you guys a hundred dollar cash
bonus all right refinancing student debt
earnest.com fighter terms conditions
apply now ernest giving you guys again a
hundred dollar bonus refinance your
student loans at earnest.com fighter
terms and conditions apply
you get a hundred dollars cash bonus
when you visit earnest.com fighter to
refinance your student loan not
available in all states term conditions
apply earnest.com fighter this episode
of firing the kid is brought to you by
butters and on its supplements honest
supplements whatever supplement you need
it's fun to be thick but be healthy
thick man whatever you need alpha brain
total gut health we got shroom tech we
got key minerals we got protein powders
up the gazoo we got a keto collection we
got uh coffee we have like i said keto
stuff mct oil whey protein plant
plant-based protein butters is licking
me we have elk bars warrior bars fitness
gear for your thick ass whatever you
need man on demand workout streaming
fitness at the crib on it sandbags
battle rope steel club maces save 10
percent off of everything go to on
it.com fighter for tim's off the best
supplements in the world
what's up thinkies oh don't mind me just
doing the reads with this cute-ass puppy
this little golden wiener dog his name's
butters welcome butters to the studio
he's gonna pipe down for me while i do
these uh reeds and stuff uh before we
get into this juicy ass episode with the
kid and backflip lacy uh san antonio
this saturday one show saturday night
one show is this saturday with uh derek
poston is hosting you got david lucas
chappelle lacey myself between one hell
of a show only one show saturday night
in san antonio texas bud light courtyard
event center come and get it san antonio
tickets are left but not many let's sell
this [ __ ] out then denver colorado i'm
coming home my hometown comedy works
downtown denver is next thursday friday
and saturday that's september 30th
through the 2nd then las vegas nevada at
wiseguys the new club in las vegas
nevada october 7th through october 9th
brea california is october 15th through
october 17th then i have a special one
in dallas texas november 11th through
the 13th as we get closer i'll fill you
guys in but that's a big night for your
boy what do you got jen
oh okay
sales are picking up in uh colorado just
got a text
oh nice thanks denver
thanks denver
you're on the cloud again thursday
friday saturday you're there next
weekend i know the following weekend
buddy it's gonna be good are you guys
are you staying at the uh the condo
though i'm staying at a no i'm a hotel
why they have the best condo because my
feature and my
my mc are staying at the condo oh there
you go hotel yeah what hotel you stand
down there um
down at uh i'll be in boulder
oh nice well
really nice house in boulder
that's far bubba 35 minutes no
i went to school there
how long who told you that people
why would you stay in boulder when your
shoals are in general people
that's so stupid okay
who booked this why did you ask him he's
from my last lots of money
and told you to stay in boulder i got a
nice house yeah i don't give a [ __ ] give
me drive i mean
40 minutes at least dude and on thursday
friday you're like an hour and a half
come on stop oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah you'll figure it out that's so
stupid that'd be like having shows in
hollywood what else happened
no you don't though spain of interior
though now you're trying to cover it up
that's like staying in la and then
your shows are in la and you're in
orange county
shut up yeah
come on yeah is that true right long
beach
that's a long way it's like where's your
show's at comedy store we staying long
beach
oh all right it's nice up there though
yeah well i do have a hotel as well yeah
for a saturday you'll be fine but
thursday and friday will be tough all
right just leave early you'll be fine
yeah just traffic panty ass yeah
sorry what do you got okay no real quick
i want to ask you guys when you watch uh
movies on your tv whatever you know that
smoothing feature
it's like way more framed so you know
like a soap opera you look at soap it
looks different than an actual tv show
so the movies are doing that now with
tvs do you guys prefer that or do you
prefer like the tvs i've seen it oh yeah
i don't really can't tell the difference
they took the hdr yeah it's and that
works like slurry behind and then the
main characters sort of like that but
it's more like that [ __ ] it's just way
more shots like 24 frames per second is
24 shots for that second and now it's
like up to 120 or something like i can't
crazy i don't know what it is it looks
too real it looks too real it looks too
real so when you watch a movie you know
i hate that too i don't like it they
look like they're it's super imposed
yeah it looks weird it also looks like
you're right there with them which i
want to make i want to make it like a
real movie like i'm not there so you
know ufc camera when they always walk
out like i do like the movies getting
released at home though too yeah as a
parent it really helps with that thing
you can see the blood looks really fake
all that stuff yeah it's too hot yeah
it's two it's way too high definition
all right just the thought
and people look not that good you can
see everything you can see like the
makeup and [ __ ]
so people are making fun of conor
mcgregor online because he threw out the
first pitch at a baseball game and
they're comparing his pitch to 50 cents
it's that bad it's bad so but is his
legs better
what's that i think 50 cents he doesn't
throw balls remember he's from yeah and
he hasn't they don't throw balls look at
his suit england he's from dublin i mean
doubling this right now
that's not right here he goes
oh [ __ ] all the way to the right
right in practice or anything
yeah yeah that's bad that's is it as bad
as 50s was still i mean yeah 50s is
worse there's a video of
[ __ ] someone comparing both of it
50s
there it is
50s is so [ __ ] bad they went the
opposite directions right yeah yeah
i would say 50s is worse it's way worse
you're just either facing at the wrong
time
the only good thing is this goes viral
like if it would've been straight down
the pipe like a strike yeah we were just
talking about that yeah like if you want
to get like coverage you do this [ __ ]
yeah those are some tight pants it might
have been just the jacket so do you
think he did it on purpose then no no
potentially i just don't think he
probably it's hard i think it's hard
he just didn't train at all he just
thought he could do it one of the things
when you see like you ever watch a
european throw a football they don't
know how to throw a football really no
they don't throw footballs in europe so
you just it's like they'll do it this
way they throw it the way they do a
soccer ball so they're a rugby ball but
you don't that was bad though that was
really bad does he throw a football his
legs better yeah for sure so brendan i
wanted to get your opinion on this billy
eilish recently came out and said that
she has a new collab out with air jordan
that's all i know jordan does now is
collab yeah it's only where they stay
relevant really really really all they
do is collabs do they not sell well
otherwise smart right they sell good but
their collabs are like the biggest yeah
because they're exclusive scott clabs
all the drake collabs they've done so
these are her two shoes i don't like
that i don't like the i like the ones
those are nice those i can't tell what
those are those are those are ones
i guess they're just green i can't tell
and you look for her though you know how
big of a deal is she signed with jordan
[ __ ] man
she's a big deal mm-hmm they'll be
dumped though i'd have to see all of
them
yeah i wish there were more people that
one's there not any more pictures of
them
if you type in billy alice jordan's i
wonder if people have like a real shot
of them
let's go to images
they look nice oh there they are yeah
i'll dig them
yeah they're just jordan ones that are
lime green i've heard logo on top those
are cool though
isn't that her thing like she rocks like
damn the other bright green shoes or
something because her hair used to be
bright green oh okay that was kind of
like crazy those are dope i'd rock those
these bruh
yeah
this is those right here
i don't like those at all yeah those i
don't like those are all wow
the other ones are sick the other one's
just the one there's one those are
really awful though those are like those
are sick yeah there's nice yeah i'd rock
them you'd rock those yeah yeah
yeah those other ones are [ __ ]
terrible
all righty okay so recently two men in
auckland new zealand were arrested
because they're currently under a
level four lockdown over there and all
restaurants are closed including like
takeout options
and so these men drove an hour and a
half to a neighboring city which was
hamilton new zealand to get
a bunch of kfc like their trunk was
filled with nothing but kfc's hustle it
to like we still don't know whether
they're going to try to sell it or if
they were just hoarding it for the next
however long they could eat kfc for but
they
there was a trunk full of kfc and there
were suspicious suspicious activities
that was called into the police like hey
people are driving out of the city and
driving back go check it out police
officers arrested them they are now
looking at a fine of up to three
thousand dollars and six months in
prison
had like one person test positively shut
you down dude yeah [ __ ]
all of this for kfc it's like that
fighter dan hooker who fights this
weekend they weren't gonna give him a
visa and then he went online was okay
somebody helped me out to get my visa
and fans bombarded the government their
website and they responded and now he's
going to be able to fight but he was
like my entire training camp like
basically underground like had to hide
his training camp going to gyms he'd be
in the gym and cops would rush in and
shut it down what the [ __ ] yeah
auckland's russia now so that's cool
come on yeah
yeah nightmare man [ __ ]
alrighty
this just happened oh we said that
already
uh
this
a lot of people have been tagging us in
this dylan danis apparently was at the
jersey shore
last weekend
and
he caused some sort of a ruckus and then
he was actually choked out by a security
guard or a police officer
and i'll show you the video well this is
tom de blasio's angle
i think he's a jiu jitsu guy
what did he do
he basically was just disorderly conduct
so maybe he was just too drunk and
just acting crazy yeah it's kind of
spiraling out of control yeah
and he was wearing a knee brace outside
his pants too just like me
so i'll show you the choke out thing
here
this is the security guard or the
security he's tapping he's tapping right
here
why is kitty guard choking him out
who knows maybe he was like i don't know
he has like
he's grabbing with his legs too right
like a body triangle
got it this is a security guard not the
cop i think it's a security guard yeah
it's weird that guy was able to get his
back yeah but i mean if he's drunk
if he's super drunk he can't you know
it's hard to defend yourself when you're
super drunk
yes guys not doing well man yeah so i we
didn't know if it was him because it's
hard to tell right yeah you can't really
tell right there it's definitely him
yeah
um so there he goes right there
what the [ __ ] was he doing and then we
saw this so it pretty much is him
according to this and they roasted yeah
damn mug shot
yeah that's nice is he is he a troubled
guy
i didn't think so i didn't
do you know i don't know
i didn't think so though he's been out a
while he had that knee surgery yeah so
he's recovering from his knee stuff
that's a lot yeah
that's tough you have the canelo stuff
on i do jesus christ that was this is
probably the best angel do you see what
happened to the guy's [ __ ] face yeah
we have it here too did you kill the
plant's face he got [ __ ] up man no and
it's just a translation mistake because
you know they're pushing each other and
then
canelo thought he was talking [ __ ] about
his mom but caleb plant said
[ __ ] oh canelo thought he was
talking [ __ ] about his
mom of course there's a translation
error there right so that's why canelo
can all sock them in the [ __ ] face
all right so this is ariel that was the
show on his instagram you sign with
showtime
showtime pay per view he calls the
[ __ ] that's why canelo pushes
him push him here now watch that look
how fast this is so fast you don't look
like much boom boom that left hook
blasted his eye open simply that fast
and then look at this oh [ __ ] that's the
damage
[ __ ] i couldn't even see the punch gets
in the way of training actually yeah
he'll be all right that's not their
fights in november so it should be fun
it's a bad [ __ ] yeah tough fight
oh it's con
plant it's a tough fight for canelo
though too
i think the only thing is if he can keep
if he if kale can keep him at bay with
that with his punches he punches hard
man he's a very good boxer tough fight
yeah
and then people are saying that he never
landed us the first shot so caleb posted
this that he did him hit him with a
slack i want to see where canelo did
though
did canelo had it hit him
he did
his cheek right here yeah right but but
it was like
yeah it was a quick left that we
couldn't even see
watch
he says [ __ ] and he's like oh
it's about my mom pushes and then you'll
see here
what
it's like
yeah it's that fast
so fast yeah it's so quick
so [ __ ] cool canelo is the pound for
pound number one in mind so
yeah right now yeah for sure
definitely a top five for caleb
definitely but
it'll be interesting
i'm very i'm very much looking forward
to this you want to bet on it
go for it brian go for it brian what
would what would be the uh whatever you
want stipulations go forward what do you
mean
i think it goes
oh i'll bet you canelo finishes them
you think so yeah yeah i'll bet you
that's it have you watched kale plant
fight yes i have watched that thing
ain't going a distance somebody's
getting knocked down excellent fighter
yep bet on it
bigger bet on it hits his heart brown
you got this
i love taking your mic you don't know
what you're talking about
kale plant is
[Laughter]
really good yup names three opponents he
spot mike lee
um
and i don't know the other two but i
watched that yeah yeah but he looks very
good he he's undefeated
yeah
bet on it yeah
i might have to bet on it they'll do it
now what would you want to bet what
would you want to bet i'll bet you
it doesn't go to decision canelo wins by
tk or ko
how many how many rounds is the fight
would be 12-round fight
that's boxing yeah it's championship
round round they change those things up
never
fight under 12.
it's boxing yeah
yeah
i'll take that back bet your gran
oh boy oh
that caleb wins no that that it goes to
the
dude
i think if anybody's gonna beat canelo
it's caleb plant he's hard and he's a
very [ __ ] good boxer how much do you
think that messes with his head though
this thing
that he
landed is can he keep
canelo
at distance yeah because it's you know
but he's just as big and he's not afraid
of him that's another part of it yeah
he's just ain't afraid man
and trains he's nobody's afraid at that
level i think guys but guys are kind of
like nobody that fights canelo like some
of the guys can always fight like
nobody's terrible i mean he did he did
then again he's canal's beating
everybody man including the who's the
russian guy the russian kit yeah who's
huge finished him
huge finished him it's unbelievable body
shop
yeah he's a monster he's a monster
he's you know he's fought triple g twice
yeah i had triple h he lost one yeah for
sure
yeah
but i mean still no it's a good fight
and i like caleb plant oh yeah i just
like your money better i think
so if kale plant can't
if caleb plant
can't beat him now he'll never beat him
let's put it that way kayla plants
fighting at the that the prime at the
top of this game how old is it so it's
cut out
oh look
boxing is exciting
right now
if it's the right matchup it is yeah
you know you're right 29 29 yeah he's a
[ __ ] beast he's from not i think reps
in knoxville mm-hmm
is what 31 31.
all right that's a great fight
sam adams came out with a beer that's
illegal in 15 states because of how
strong it is
how many percent do you guys think it is
[ __ ]
way more 40 no not 40. for a beer 15
above 20. wow
25. nope more
jesus so it's like 28
and uh yeah it costs 240 bucks for a
25.4 ounce bottle oh
well how come
because of the percentage of the alcohol
it's so hard to do yeah
wow what's like a bud lights what like
five yeah yeah five or four something
like that i really i would like to try
it
i want to try another i see it yeah yeah
that's why they did it yeah you know
what exactly they upped the price on the
two for it now we're talking about it
yeah
those ipas are what like eight eight
percent they can they can even go into
like thirteen percent yeah this one
typically they're why does it have a
picture of uh i don't know that's
probably just the uh the article if you
hit play does it show it let's see
that's his wife why the bear uses
no not that
cnn does that sometimes yeah
unrelated to unrelated articles
i'd like to see what it looks like
and this is marketing though yeah for
sure this is about a week old but i
thought this was interesting blue face
is bad you saw this [ __ ] man
do you see them checking up on the
valley i think this is oh in the valley
yes in the valley so i'll show you the
video real quick it's bad really so some
bounce uh one bouncer i don't know why
there's only one bouncer we wouldn't let
the guys in for some reason and they
would they wouldn't let him in i know so
blueface went to this bar
and didn't have any id oh and blueface
was his entourage and you know it's just
a bouncer and he's like i'm blue face
let me and he's like well i don't know
who you are i need an id he's like i
have my id look me up he's like it
doesn't work that way i need to id and
then they beat the [ __ ] out of this guy
oh he's [ __ ] it even blue face doesn't
like but oh [ __ ]
wait do you see this it's going to pitch
you and why is there only one bouncer
that's well it's just a bar
especially in the valley yeah it's not
like
wait this is a different video hold on
this one gets shot
you've heard of blue face right brian
yeah oh he's a rapper
so this is the bounce right here right
there oh that's the bounce yeah it
doesn't even look like a bouncer
and that's blue face in that tank top
this boy and his crew just like smacks
you what the [ __ ] at him obviously this
guy is like what the hell oh no
and then i don't know why and the girls
the girls filming it yeah
[ __ ]
just shitty
people still hitting them
uh there you go yeah that was brave but
you do i know dude wait wait wait wait
wait wait did you see what blue face
does so the guy's like so that's blue
face on the jersey tall dude yeah there
he is now the guy's like trying to crawl
away and get away
blueface is still talking [ __ ] now watch
this
stops him again stomps his head in
what they're still [ __ ] hitting them
these guys are so bad now look at bloofy
stomping his head again
good luck dude you're gonna you're gonna
go to jail now
the guy didn't even try to fight he's
trying to like stop i mean he's got
four dudes another stop yeah now watch
bluefin yeah when i watch everyone
leaves now watch what blue face does
wow you're such a man blue face
you're so brave it looks like he's drunk
too right i don't know kind of stumbling
a little bit i can't tell but look at
this slaps him in the face they're
saying he slapped him to make sure he
was still conscious
he's trying to check if he's still
conscious
and then he bounces
okay he's [ __ ] enjoy that dumbass
yeah i wonder what they do with it oh he
goes to jail definitely he's going to do
more importantly he'll be in court and
whatever money he has is going to be
he's [ __ ] the best i guess
he's going to someone says that he just
paid his whatever all his bills
did they did they say like like they
took the homie to the hospital and
willie died willie i knew william garcia
he's dyed it which one oh from sex in
the city
oh yeah i just saw this earlier in the
morning hold on let's go to the other
one let's finish this story let me see
his face yeah
[ __ ] yeah
some guy trying to work for a living and
they just stomped and he wasn't even
trying to fight him he was trying to
okay he's gonna make a lot of money how
much does blueface have a lot of money
he should oh i don't know a million
dollars he had to do a fight so maybe
not as much as he had before yeah like
you would think yeah well
all right so let's look at what we're
doing johnson and i worked with uh he
was a great guy hilarious and william
carson i worked with many times that's
sad three times oh cancer cancer
freaking cancer oh you just found this
out now i did
um i mean i knew him pretty damn well i
did uh
saxon city with him and i did um [ __ ]
uh californication with him and then i
would see him periodically yeah that
sucks
and anthony johnson you guys know him so
smokey smokey over here taking a [ __ ]
what kind of cancer he said i'll shut
the hell up
he died of cancer he was hilarious no no
no no [ __ ] answer johnson was such a
good guy
they said he collapsed at a dude you're
gonna love this [ __ ] he i did a
movie with him nobody saw he's so
[ __ ] hilarious so funny oh he was so
funny so funny he was such a good guy
man and hilarious
like hilarious like one of those special
dudes man that's a bummer i know people
are just passing away yeah but dude uh
willie willie garcia yeah let me see
what the cancer oh pancreatic oh [ __ ]
that for for willie
that'll kill you three months
oof that's a bummer yeah that sounds
great
all right on a lighter note
i don't know if this is rumors or if
it's true but chelsea handler they went
on their instagram i think made it
chelsea did joe yeah so apparently
chelsea's dating jo koi which is great
good for them yeah yeah they've known
each other forever she's great
she's in love all right finally in love
two powerhouses i know they go way back
yeah way [ __ ] back 20 years it's
awesome i love those stories i think
it's funny that the media doesn't
realize how big of a comedian jokoya is
like you would know him as a parent on
chelsea handler show and like some other
[ __ ] it's like bruh it's like that
[ __ ] no he's a monster comedian
and also just had steven spielberg
direct his movie yeah how do you guys
not do your
he sold out research golden the new
golden state warriors arena before they
played it twice
and before they even got to sold out the
form twice yeah
we are we have the same
agent and he was saying that netflix for
the longest time would you note him no
no no finally
yeah well congrats to them yeah
and let's go here
so
thor or the mountain
he's being super ripped lately [ __ ]
look at that god damn he was so big yeah
he's looking good man
and apparently he had a boxing match i
didn't realize
hold on yeah he won right yeah yeah
that's him at the boxing match the other
guy got so tight he's jacked another big
dude i'm not sure what oh it says uh
eddie hall right but then yeah he
bounced out they stopped the fight he
was good yeah yeah so it was standing
let's see
i'll show you the finisher it's so crazy
he's that big and just
ripped like super lean he's the
strongest man in the world i mean he was
yeah he was yeah it was staying real
calm this guy got so tired oh yeah yeah
he got so tired it's just they stopped
it right here just too much he's so big
dude oh god
how tall is he like
like six eight or something something
crazy yeah i'm huge six eight he's huge
god damn it
giant
six nine
seven feet yeah he's strong
32 years old 69 345 pounds his wife is
five two i know she's so tiny
oh super cute i guess he's uh got he had
palsy on his
face it comes and goes so he had a
stroke he had a stroke
but that's his uh that's his girl he's
great
she's so tiny she's super hot though oh
she's adorable
but so tiny he's enormous look at this
this is invisible
yeah i mean he's who is that is that his
dad yeah his dad's maybe her i don't
know that's big time that's huge his dad
is [ __ ] i would have liked to see him
and eddie hall go at it yeah that would
have been better i don't even know this
other guy holy [ __ ] he's big look how
big his legs are that's so weird it is
right like how they
so many questions i would
not be mad if a sex tape came out
so curious to say that i just like to
see how it goes down we all we all got
this question some cool stuff on there
man like their child is going to be
probably very normal
yeah average out 5'2 that's she's such a
trip very [ __ ] cute super cute he's
so big but he's enormous he's [ __ ]
massive yeah they are kissing each other
this must be photoshopped though yeah
this is photoshop oh no that has to be
photos yeah the arm is just
that big yeah that's like real hair
that's really yeah i want to see him and
eddie hall though fight
yeah look at this eddie hall's rip now
too
let's see
and he has the i think he has the
heaviest deadlift in the world jesus
i watched that documentary on him
he's great oh yeah he lost a ton away
yeah yeah there's a video of him running
what the hell is this he runs every day
it looks almost like implants about the
different types of protein is his
stomach yeah now the two proteins i take
mainly are the impact uh i don't care
about your protein tell us about your
[ __ ] cycle bubba
yeah because that's what he looked like
before right oh come on oh [ __ ] yeah he
had the heaviest deadlift what kind of i
wonder what kind of gear they do ronda
name of steroids
what was what was his deadlift over a
thousand pounds it was like geez 1100
pounds there is a transformation there's
a video of oh my god how thick he is he
was a bowling ball with arms yeah that
is [ __ ] so strong
i mean he looks like that street that
dude from street fighter that's
dangerous
yeah
more like
hey that's more than a thousand pounds
one thousand one hundred eleven hundred
pounds yeah i can't still eleven hundred
pounds
there's a video of arnold cheering him
on say come on do it oh that's that's oh
that's who that is they got oh okay okay
that is so nuts that kind of weight
nattos yeah
um i mean your 600 is still insane too
though i think i'm far off i am from
that who's this guy arnold's boy his son
yeah and he's at uh gold yes
venice i liked him before
what do you mean
i'm not crazy about that look right
there oh he looks good man okay if your
dad's arnold i disagree but okay
what's wrong he can't look like that
brian i i just liked him before that's
all i have that's my opinion there you
go
he looks good yeah he's got a good body
um
what was i going to show you guys
well here's a fun fight
this is the the cleveland browns yeah i
forgot what the actual game who are they
playing but the brown still watch this
it's enjoyable
why are they fighting let's go get it
get it
get it [ __ ] eyeball the
porta-potties
that's like a dad yeah yeah it gets
crazier
it gets crazier
oh oh
and now this is
oh that big the big black guy gets
involved i don't think he does but other
people do oh wow
there's tails
thank you sir
oh wow
god he's going to mess with the mad dog
i know right
that guy's looking for trouble
oh [ __ ] yeah it's crazy bro oh my oh
this is mayhem this is [ __ ] insane oh
wow oh wow i mean
and people just filming like usual this
table goes down what
[Applause]
jesus christ
and that should be it
jesus
would someone mess up their table that's
jacked
up long as there's no guns jesus christ
good old street fighters fight the same
level of skills the browns play football
oh damn
[Laughter]
and you mentioned this yesterday vernon
on uh king of the sting yeah i just i
found the video so you guys want to
watch it what is it i mean it's a dude
that gets bit in the balls by snake yeah
all right let's see
everyone's laughing at him
i think this might be fake it could be
fake
fake oh that's fake
you know what i agree this isn't the
video i saw oh it's a different one real
yeah oh i thought this one no the one i
saw is real yeah this one you can easily
put on the shorts and this is the way
the guy was like grabbing the snake
okay see what that guy's doing dude
wasn't scared at all after seeing a wild
crocodile go see that right there
let's see that's right yeah now you know
why this is nuts why because if he [ __ ]
up and that that gator grabs on his
[ __ ] hand which we've seen before
we'll see you later you're getting
pulled into that water
whoa it's all pushing her nose
i guess that's a wild croc he's he's
he's obviously looking for a chicken or
food
because he's used to humans feeding them
his mouth opens
mouth is messed up yeah except for this
is in this is in australia
of course and i don't like that
um you're right though i think he's used
to getting chicken
yeah he's probably just waiting for him
to throw him something remember in costa
rica
yeah those were different crocs but yeah
but still they were like so used to
humans yeah
yeah years ago
give me the goddamn chick
then you were like
that big one
dude think of that crocodile i don't
feel like doing this yeah game over yeah
is that it i think that's it all righty
all right dude i'm going to denver
tonight boys you're going to denver dude
steve even tonight good to see you buddy
you leaving tonight or not i'm leaving
tonight i'm doing press tomorrow morning
oh okay oh yeah daddy
i'm doing your boys i'm doing uh the
radio stations scott hastings yes oh
those are my guys this is great and
what's her name he went to school with
uh yeah yeah uh 106.7 kbpi yep
really
willie's my guy yeah biggest gearhead
you know is that right and the other guy
played pro football
um uh alfred williams i don't know if
he's still on there yeah anyway i would
that'd be fun yeah yeah
that'd be fun i'd like to even yeah i
missed those guys yeah
go see brian this weekend denver
colorado chicago illinois september 30th
october 1 october 2 at the schomburg
improv and columbus ohio funny bone
october 8th and 9th let's go and then
saturday at 4 00 p.m and that is texas
time 4 p.m text time that's 5 p.m
eastern time chin if you bring it up
there instagram it's the downtown
showdown
i'm doing a q a to raise money to fight
kidney disease it'll be a 60 minute q
and a downtown showdown fire away man if
you want to
uh submit any questions
uh submit your question that thick fan
that's thick with three c's thick fan
at thickboy.com and your questions will
get answered on saturday at 5 p.m
eastern and i'll blast everything out
where you can uh watch it at and all
that stuff with the downtown
showdown that ain't it no
it said to knock out kidney disease go
back yeah you'll see it when you type it
in downtown
and you do it the way you did yeah yeah
and then watch you'll see knockout yeah
there it is showdown downtown knockout
kidney disease this one that's it okay
yeah
yep
dr faisal
yep so that is saturday at 5 pm eastern
it says 6 p.m there but i think that's
uh a different time but yeah i'll be on
their far and away questions awesome so
uh and then also after that
saturday bud light courtyard event
center san antonio it's on there they
have two shows it's one show saturday
the 25th the crew will be out there
saturday saturday night in san antonio
texas bud light courtyard event center
and then i'm in denver colorado come on
out from mama i'm coming home yep
saturday 30th september 30 through
october 2nd then las vegas nevada
october 7th through october 9th then
bray is october 15th through october
17th and we got a very special thing
going on dallas tech this november 11th
through november 13th
that's it man take us at f a t k z dot
com your mom uh your mom getting you
even say she said she's not going
to she's not going to she's not going to
see brian what about aunt she said two
weekends in the row is too much
nubby nub's not coming my mom come in
maybe the b maybe the sneak in dude is
your bro going to come to my show i got
to call you he's in san antonio with me
october 7th through the 9th i'll be in
tampa florida at sidesplitters and
october 28th through the what is it
30th i'll be in washington dc at the dc
comedy loft happy birthday christian
happy birthday all right kids we're out